Hi everyone, my name is Sai Vennam
and I'm with the IBM Cloud team.
Today we want to talk about operators,
and no, I'm not actually talking about operations teams,
but instead the operators framework
which can be used on Kubernetes or OpenShift.
CoreOS actually introduced the operator framework back in 2016.
CoreOS is now a part of Red Hat and IBM.
Operator framework is quickly picking up traction
as it's a great way of managing complex Kubernetes applications.
Now, before I jump into this,
we want to actually introduce what the Kubernetes control loop is
because it's a core part of the operators framework.
In this video, we're going to be talking about things like deployments and pods,
so if you're not familiar with those
be sure to check out the"Kubernetes Explained" video
that I've done on those topics.
But let's get started with exactly what the control loop is
in Kubernetes.
Now, essentially the way it starts,
the control loop is the core part of Kubernetes,
it observes the state of what's in your actual cluster.
So, that's the first step: "observe".
Next, what it's going to do,
Kubernetes is going to double-check
that the state in the actual cluster
versus the state that you want it to be.
So it's going to do a diff.
And finally, it wants to resolve that diff by acting on it.
So, the last phase of the control loop is
"act".
Now, the control loop is core to how Kubernetes works
and there's a controller that basically acts on that
for every default resource.
Kubernetes comes with a number of default resources.
Let's see an example of deploying an application without operators
using these default resources.
So, as an end user,
essentially the first thing you're going to want to do
is write up some YAML,
the specification for that actual application.
And, for our particular example, let's say that
we're doing a deployment.
And in this deployment, we'll have to define some configuration.
Things like, "What's the image?", and maybe
the replicas, and maybe some other configuration.
So, that's one Kubernetes resource.
And, essentially what you would do, is take that
and deploy it into your Kubernetes cluster
at which point a deployment is made.
Here's where the control loop kicks in:
so Kubernetes observes the state of your cluster,
so we've got a Kubernetes cluster here,
and checks for the difference between what you want versus what's there.
First thing it notices: there's no pods.
So, it's gonna act on that difference,
and it's gonna create some pods.
Now, let's say for a fairly complex application
we don't just have  one YAML
but we have a second YAML, maybe it's for the backend,
and so that deploys in the second deployment,
and that in turn deploys a pod
using the controllers in the control loop.
Now, it's a simple example, but say you want to go through here,
scale up the application, make some changes,
set up some secrets, environment variables,
- every single time you have to either create new Kubernetes resources,
or go in here and edit the existing ones.
That can start to get fairly difficult.
Now, let's see how that's done in a world where we're using operators.
Now, the first thing you would need to do
is install the operator itself.
So, someone on your team has to create the operator,
or maybe you can use one of the many that are out there on OperatorHub,
or the community is building on the operators that are available.
So, the first thing you need in your Kubernetes cluster
is the OLM,  which is the "Operator Lifecycle Manager",
which basically manages operators that you have installed.
Next, you deploy your actual operator into the cluster.
The operator is made up of two major components.
The first component in an operator is going to be the CRD.
The other one is going to be the controller.
Now, the CRD is basically a "Custom Resource Definition".
So, we've talked about default resources -  things like deployments and pods.
A custom resource is something that you define as a user in Kubernetes,
or maybe an operator defines, it so that you can create YAML
to work against that custom config.
The controller is basically a custom control loop
which runs as a pod in your cluster
and runs this control loop against your custom resource definition.
So, let's say that an operator is created for our custom application deployment here,
so instead  of having to write multiple deployments
and setting up config maps and secrets for whatever our cluster needs,
we instead, as an end user, we'll just deploy one YAML.
Maybe we called this operator MyApp.
It could be a little bit more meaningful  - we can call it "stateful app", "front-end app",
whatever we want it to be.
And then, we could define some config here,
or we can use the defaults that are set.
We of have a choice of options here.
Then we take this operator
and we deploy it directly into the cluster.
At this point the operator takes over,
and this is actually responsible for running that control loop,
and figuring out exactly what needs to be running.
So, it's going to realize that
we need a couple of deployments and the pods.
Now, this is a kind of a format, or an approach
to managing applications
that's inherently easier - and scales better - than this approach,
because, as an end-user, you really only have to worry about
the config that's been exposed to you,
and the operator itself manages the control  loop
and the state of the application - how it needs to look.
Now, there are great operators out there already,
things like managing etcd, or various databases,
or even IBM Cloud Services.
So, all of those operators currently exist on OperatorHub.
But say you want to develop your own, maybe a custom operator for
for something that is native to your application architecture,
kind of like what we sketched out here.
Well, there's a number of ways you can do that.
And there's something called Operator SDK that allows you
to start building out operators yourself.
Now, I'd say the easiest way to get started with an operator,
is to use the Helm operator.
So, Helm.
As you may already know,
there is a video that where David Okun goes over exactly how Helm works.
Be sure to check that one out.
The Helm approach allows you to take a Helm chart
and apply that towards an operator, expose config -
so, it allows you to get to a fairly mature level of an operator.
Kind of something like this for a chart that's already there.
Now the maturity of operators, what I've sketched out down here,
falls into 5 different levels.
Now, Helm actually hits the first 2 levels of maturity.
Let's talk about what  those levels are.
The first one is a basic install.
Essentially, the first level is basically going to allow you to do
just provisioning of the resources  required.
Now, the second phase goes a little bit further
it's gonna allow you to do upgrades.
So, this supports minor and patch version upgrades
to whatever is defined in your operator.
Now Helm gets you that far,
what about for the next 3 levels of maturity?
For these, you're going want to use either Go,
or, you can also use Ansible.
Now, these will allow you to actually get to
all 5 levels of maturity with operators.
Let's quickly talk about what those are.
At the third level, we've got full lifecycle support.
So, this is storage lifecycle, app lifecycle.
It's also going to allow you to do things like backup and failure recovery.
So, that's something that would be configured
and developed into the operator,
who ever developed that one.
Fourth, what we've got here is insights.
This is going to allow you to get deep metrics, and analysis,
logging, that kind of thing, from your actual operator.
And finally, what we have is something called "autopilot".
And just as the name implies,
this is going to have a lot more functionality built into operator itself.
Basically it's going to allow you to do automatic scaling,
- horizontal and vertically.
It's going to do automatic config tuning.
If your operator-based app gets into a bad state,
it's gonna identify that automatically.
So, these are the 5 levels of maturity that operators can have.
By looking on OperatorHub, you can see
the ones that the community has developed
and see what level of maturity that they hit,
and then, again, by using operator SDK,
you can build your own operators using either Helm, Go, or Ansible.
Thanks for joining me for this  video on operators.
If you have any questions be sure to drop us a line  below.
If you want to see more videos like this in the future,
please "like' and subscribe.
And don't forget, you can always get started on the cloud at no cost
by signing up for a free IBM Cloud account.